save big on the hottest games exclusive
bundles and more this winter with
fanatical
[Music]
from the studio turning formulaic movies
into a literal formula comes the average
of every blockbuster you've ever watched
with stars playing the average of every
character they've ever played that feels
like the average of every meal you ate
from the microwave because anything else
was too much effort
red notice
smash that back button or red notice
will autoplay whether you want it to or
not because netflix is betting you'll at
least half watch these a-listers even if
they're doing craigslist level material
in an action comedy calculated to lock a
global audience to their couch and drain
them of the will to reach for the remote
full of sexy people
occasional action and humor dumbed down
to the universal language of mugging
joke free bickering you found it who's
found it there's no bunker there's
here there's nothing out here
or when all else fails
just naming apps people have heard of
etsy kind of like alexa but with guns
she sent me the only place on earth that
actually is worse than her instagram
account
yeah venmo doordash tick tock am i right
fellow children
prepare to see the rock where he's never
been before
no not the jungle i mean come on might
as well be in his contract at this point
i mean the personal space of a female
co-star watch the sexual charisma
trickle off the screen as the rock
transforms into
basically himself but this time he's
part of the fbi's something something
made up jobs department john hartley of
the fbi's behavioral analysis unit he's
a consulting profiler who specializes in
art crime sure study agent hartley's
every move because there may be more to
this art cop than meets the eye i called
up the assistant director of the bau at
quantico she'd never heard of you i know
how confident scheme works trust me he's
a pretty damn good thief for his first
time hmm
why are you shooting at them i thought
you were on their side ah
hardly so it was you all along
such a clever disguise just a few more
hints the data says one subscriber in
guam doesn't see it coming yet you're
not a cop
you're right or not you're right i'm the
bad guy
okay he's got it deploy the twist yeah
we're both the bishop gasp
what would ryan reynolds be without
deadpool this guy the thief with the
teeth shines as another anti-hero who
sprays rapid-fire jokes at you until one
of them hits two birds one egg it's kind
of a layup even post malone gets it this
is farm to table right and never met a
fourth wall he couldn't break we dress
up in matching black pajamas and sneak
past the featured extras and into the
bedroom that's called foreshadowing look
for a box that says mcguffin i love the
money thrill as the talented mr reynolds
pulls off the heist of the century get
paid to do a movie then use it to
promote his gin company because if they
sell enough bottles he gets like half a
billion dollars dude you got 20 million
for this movie alone is that really
necessary these people are
horrible but i like money so fair
gal gadot returns for the second most
ill-advised singing of her career
she's the bishop an art thief with the
superpower to be everywhere all the time
let me save you the trouble your
entrances are bullsh and while she could
use her powers to just rob nolan after
he's found what she's looking for this
plunder woman and her bff have 24
unnecessary steps to check off before
that happens
okay let's see here check
well you got to do that one
okay i guess
that that definitely seems like it
should be important but it's not
maybe they didn't want the money all
along and this was just the easiest way
to get ed cheering tickets
that was so iconic iconic it's bad right
thrill at three art thieves who clearly
don't give a about art or
antiquities while they play a cat and
mouse game with interpol an organization
who can't do jack besides dramatically
burst into a room
this is an interpol police action remain
in your seats soto voce an arms dealer
whose vote sounds like he who should not
be named is that so
and the real villains of the film bad
dads my father was a prolific ass my dad
was a crook on my 13th birthday he
didn't show up my mom and i never saw
him again i know it sounds like a tough
childhood but my father made me who i am
today his dad tried to strangle him when
he was 14. yep they definitely owe the
mcu a royalty check on this one also the
dceu
also indiana jones
[Music]
also my little pony you've had me hiking
in circles for eight hours what does the
map say
[Music]
it feels like we're going in circles are
you suggesting that i'm reading the map
wrong the map is also upside down
so crank that playback speed up to 1.25
and settle in for the movie equivalent
of a mashup parody t-shirt that's not
the complete disaster critics are making
it out to be just a series of images
in the vague shape of a movie and sounds
in the shape of jokes that will drift
into the same memory hall where all
netflix originals live never to be
thought of or discussed ever again
until red noticed two auto plays
at the end other great british bake off
really starring
paul bellart tall cop hamburglar
mean gals dasa cobb
egg sheeran nobody expects the spanish
exposition yep looks ancient egyptian to
me hmm forbidden omelette
[Music]
five second rule and planarama dingdong
this is a plant but what's the plan the
most important part of any plant is a
good night's sleep it's the actual plan
part the most important part of the plan
step two plan ahead your last brilliant
plan had some kinks in it what's the
plan son of a that's not part of the
plan plans change is that your plan
agent hartley i love this plan you know
the kind of thing i'm into
is a good plan a smart plan the opposite
of this
too many crooks
so if the rock is also the bishop that
means gal gadot doesn't even have her
own character name that's a nice
save big on the hottest games exclusive
bundles and more this winter with
fanatical
how can ant-man breathe if he's smaller
than oxygen atoms
whatever boats your float
iso propane and propane accessories
blowsy night from's vexed jack q